hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen lektion 50 hört
zu und spricht nach
ich heiße markus
ich heiße markus ich bin super
20 jahre alt
ich bin 27 jahre alt
ich wohne in
basel ich wohne in basel
ruf mich bitte nach dem unterricht an
ich freue mich auf die ferien
kennst du mich nicht mehr
kennst du mich nicht mehr meine eltern
besuchen mich am wochenende
meine eltern besuchen mich am wochenende
kannst du mir bitte helfen
gib mir bitte bescheid gibt mir
scheidt
hör mir zu wenn ich etwas sage
kommst du zu mir kommst du zu mir wie
heißt du
wie heißt du
woher kommst du
wie alt bist du wie alt bist du
ich möchte
ich zur party eingeladen
[Musik]
ich möchte die
party einladen
ich rufe
weiter an
ich rufe die
an
ich habe
fragt ob du zur party kommen kannst
ich habe dich gefragt ob du zur party
kommen kannst
wann
kann ich dich besuchen
wann kann ich dich besuchen
ich habe dir eine e mail geschrieben ich
habe dir eine e mail geschrieben
ich gratuliere dir zum geburtstag
wie geht es dir
ich danke dir für das geschenk
beantworte die fragen schreibt die
antworten in die kommentare
wir verlosen eine stunde
privatunterricht
das ist die neue nachbarin
sie wohnt im dritten stock
sie kommen
aus umgaben
sie kommt aus ungarn
kennst du sie kennst du sie
[Musik]
ich sehe sie immer wenn sie in die
waschküche geht
ich habe sie zu einem
das waren eingeladen
ich habe sie zu einem glas wein
eingeladen
ich habe ihr
und in anderen nachbarn erzählt
ich habe
ich habe ihr gesagt dass frau meier
immer reklamiert
ich habe
fakt dass frau meier immer reklamiert
sie hat mich
fragt ob ich den nachbarn im ersten
stock kenne
sie hat mich gefragt ob ich den nachbarn
im ersten stock kenne
ich habe ihr geantwortet dass ich nur
seinen namen kenne
ich habe ihr
das sich nur seinen namen kenne
er heißt mit nach
muster
er heißt mit nachnamen muster und er ist
schweizer und ledig
und er ist schweizer und ledig mehr weiß
ich nicht über ihn
mehr weiß ich nicht über ihn
aber die nachbarin möchte ihn
kennenlernen
aber die
der ihn kennenlernen
ich glaube
sie ist in ihn verliebt
ich glaube sie ist in ihn verliebt
ich werde bei ihm klingeln und ihm das
sagen
ich werde ihm
nummer von anja geben
ich werde ihm die telefonnummer von anja
geben
er kann ihr dann schreiben
er kann ihr dann schreiben und sie wird
ihm sicher antworten
und sie wird ihm sicher antworten aber
niemandem davon
aber
sonst erzähle ich dir nie mehr ein
geheimnis
abonniere unseren kanal zu welchem thema
sollen wir die nächsten videos machen
schreib in die kommentare